so yeah today i'm gonna
talk about scala async and both
the the project as well as a good chunk
of the slides is
actually joint work with jason zaug my
colleague at typesafe
so that's essentially our
project that aims to do
what actually c-sharp and f-sharp have
been
pretty good at in our opinion
and i must say that so i've been working
on
a bunch of async and concurrent
programming models in the past
with like actors joint patterns futures
and so forth
but it's kind of like this um
scala async and things like the f-sharp
async workflows c-sharp async like there
is something
about these models where they hit a nice
sweet spot
in my opinion uh and i'm gonna try and
convey this
uh in this talk a little bit because for
asynchronous programming there's
you know there's a whole bunch of
programming models that are out there
and try to simplify things
but i feel like every one of these
models at some point hits a wall
because you always have to somehow
manage suspension
resumption you know uh responding to to
incoming events and so forth
and um if you don't get at least some
support from either the compiler
or some macro or a way that sort of can
transform your code
it's always going to be difficult in
some way
and so async is really it's a it's a
very nice project in the sense that
it i think it can help you really
simplify your your async code
so what's the problem well um actually
the previous talk here on
reactive extensions actually had a good
good intro to this basically we have
we we we have all these events coming
into our apps and like if you want to
write a responsive
web application uh you need to use
uh you need to use some some sort of
async
programming and there again there's a
bunch of programming models they each
have their strengths
and best sort of killer apps right
there's
actors which are extremely good at
messaging remoting clustering fault
tolerance
right encapsulation
so forth isolation and there's but
there's also futures right for example
also in c sharp you use tasks a lot in
scala we have
now in scala 210 we finally have a nice
futures and promises library that
i've also been involved with and
so these are sort of extremely important
libraries essentially but they can still
be hard to use
no matter how hard we try to come up
with nice
apis right the other thing is
if you want to make sure your app scales
uh and is is high performance um
you need to use uh you know at the
lowest level you need to use
uh things like low and like non-blocking
primitives like compare and swap and all
these things right
on the lowest level but um
building on top of these things uh it
sort of your code tends to become
unnatural
right that's uh it's sort of a it's a
art right the art of multi-processor
programming right
so and uh with async we're sort of
trying to
make it so that your code becomes much
more natural while at the same time
uh using sort of the best
most efficient non-blocking apis under
the hood
so and again our inspiration actually
comes from
c-sharp and f-sharp so
c-sharp 5.0 introduced uh async and
await
that actually uh was was also mentioned
in the previous talk
and uh you know we don't claim that
we're sort of
heavily innovating on the the
programming model because it's actually
a pretty good one
done by an amazing team that's been
doing uh really really great stuff with
it and
i've really been happy to that i you
know
been talking to to people involved with
this
on and off and so so we're sort of
avoiding nih which is uh
can be a good thing right but of course
we also have our own twist to these
things
uh which makes it quite interesting
especially at
towards the end of the talk i'm gonna
show you some things that are enabled by
our approach
which is basically uh we're not building
it into the language
right we're not we didn't extend scala
the language
it's not built into the compiler instead
what we're providing is a macro library
so macros are quite a new feature
of scala it's an experimental feature
of scala 210 and uh
you know it's still sort of incubating
right so
there's work being done on on you know
what's supposed to become the stable
version of macros at some point but you
know it's very usable
today and there's an amazing number of
applications for those things
and uh for us really using this macro
facility
had a lot of advantages right
on the one hand we can actually ship
a stable implementation that works not
only for
the upcoming scala 211 but it also works
for scala 210 so you can actually
try it out today you can even if you're
confident you can use it
as is right and the other aspect is
besides the sort of simplified packaging
of our async module
the other aspect is it's more easy to
extend and adapt
given that it's just a macro library and
i'm going to
tell you a little bit about some
experience experiments that we've been
doing
that actually tie into the reactive
extensions that we
that donna and matt have been talking
right before this talk
so this talk is going to be very short
i've only got three bullet points here
so i'm gonna have lots of time for
questions
just kidding never works for me so
basically gentle intro to async
you really only need to know two two
constructs
one is called async you open a block put
an expression in there and
it just declares this expression to be
asynchronous
and in fact even though by default
this is going to be executed
asynchronously
on a pool thread somewhere
that's just the default you can
customize the execution
thanks to what we call execution
contexts
that we've introduced the scala to 10
that we use for futures parallel
collections actors and so forth
they all run on an execution context and
you can plug in any one of those
here as well
and so what you get back here from this
async block is a future
and again futures are basically are very
similar to tasks
in f-sharp but futures and promises are
extremely popular in most languages
nowadays so
if you haven't looked at into those i
encourage you to
to do that so
so how can we use this well you can use
async
just for spawning off some async
activity if you want to so the simplest
case is just to
wrap some computation that you want done
asynchronously
in an async block
but of course more common is probably
that you
get some result back and so then you get
back a future
for the result that's then going to be
completed at some point in the future
and but what you can also do is you can
just
if you have a method that should
basically run asynchronously right you
can return a future
and then you just put the entire method
body into this async
yeah you just put the entire method body
into this async
right and uh this is basically
well essentially it's an async method
right
in scala we don't really we don't have
or we didn't introduce
asynchronous methods uh in c sharp they
do right and c sharp async is actually a
modifier on method declarations
but for us you know for us we can use it
as a convention
it you know it reads quite nicely so
why not now the second
thing you need to know is a weight and
a weight is it's basically something
that allows you to
await the result of a future so you use
it inside async
and the the cool thing is that
you're waiting for the result of a
future but in a non-blocking way
so you can use a weight as much as you
want inside your async block
without any regret or bad feelings right
because it's the the async macro is
going to
take care of transforming your code
so that a weight uh just
uh registers an on completion handler on
your future
that's a a way it takes uh takes an
expression
that evaluates to a future right and um
you know it just registers
non-completion handler but this handler
is not visible in your code
yeah uh to your to you the code just
looks like as if it suspends
at that point where you call a wait and
then uh it's going to be resumed once
the future is completed
or if the future failed
you get you get an exception right but
it's really about suspension right in a
non-blocking way and again we use the
most
efficient way to do this so you really
don't have to worry about using the
weight
too much right there's no too much the
only thing you can do
is maybe reduce the amount of
parallelism in your code
right but that's possible always
but away doesn't really do any harm
right so how do we use this well let's
say we have
a bunch of futures here and again these
are these are actually just regular
scala futures and again most most of the
time you probably get futures from
you know calling into some api let's say
of like the play framework or or akka or
some other
framework so you got your futures here
and well what you can do is inside your
async block you can simply
await the completion of a future here
and you know it looks like a blocking
call essentially right because
what you do is you suspend the execution
until
you have a result and that's just a
plain
end here right nothing special about
answer
so you really sort of you automatically
suspend within this async block
yeah and a weight is really is a just a
normal expression so you can use it
anywhere you want right you can
use it as just like
a normal method
there are a couple of restrictions where
you can't use a weight so
i'm going to talk about those later but
there's not very many restrictions
so in short all you need to know is
really these two method signatures
right so async basically takes
uh a body or a block of code and
um now this block of code of course we
we don't want to evaluate on the calling
thread
right that would defeat the whole
purpose of doing asynchronous
execution so what we need to do is we
need to delay the evaluation
and in scala we do this using by name
parameters
so this leading arrow is a indicates
that this is a by name parameter
so it's not going to be evaluated before
actually calling the method or
evaluating the method
um that's going to be executed
in well in the execution context that's
in scope so i haven't shown you any
other
implicit parameters that are there
because typically you don't
you don't need to see them or use them
right and so the result is the future of
t if the body evaluates to a t
and then a weight is just dual right it
takes a future
of t and returns a t right and
if you look at a weight it really looks
like
you know old school you know synchronous
uh
blocking thing but it's sort of you know
it doesn't
can't really it's kind of can't believe
that this doesn't do any of this
uh evil blocking
so it's really good for you it tastes
good um
the question is of course do we need
this do we really need this
and i mentioned in the beginning that i
believe we
we definitely need this um
but i just want to show you a couple
examples right i'm sure
many of you are well-versed
functional programmers that write maps
and flatmaps every day
i do too but i still want to explain
this example
basically what we do is
again we obtain a bunch of futures in
this case we use play
and don't worry about the api like what
response is and things like this
all we care about are these futures and
now in scala we have all these higher
order functions like flat maven map
defined on futures and we can basically
use those to transform
a future into a new one so this future
day of year
uh we can transform into a new future
that completes once uh
this future completes and the whole body
of the
closure is is executed
so what we do is so basically disclosure
runs
as soon as this future is completed
right and then we have this response
and we can look at the body and then we
also want to know the result of this
feature
so again we call map on it which returns
a new feature
which completes once that one completes
and the closure has been evaluated to a
result that's then the result of the
result future of map right and
the result feature of map is then used
to complete
the result future of flatmap okay
but sort of the bottom line is we want
to know both results
and as soon as we have them we can
produce a response
okay so you know it's
pretty natural for fp
people but
with async it's actually much simpler
because
what do we have to do well we just wait
for the first future
that's a response we look at the body
wait for the second future
look at the body and produce the result
right so you can explain this in in two
sentences or
maybe even less whereas this one you
need to explain okay well we have a
closure and we pass it to flat map
that returns a new future and that's
completed when this happens and that
happens
right so you know arguably that's
simpler
of course in scala if you know scala you
know that there are also four
comprehensions
and those you can actually use with
futures as well and you can write
more sort of straight line code using
using four comprehensions so let's
have a look at how that would look like
and uh indeed
it looks pretty nice so what you can do
is essentially
in this four comprehension you use
generators right the first one the first
generator
says okay well once that future
completes give me the response in this
variable
and um you know same for the second
future
and then we can yield our response
and the overall result of this four
yield is again a future
uh just like in this in this well just
like in both examples before
right we always get back a future
now this looks pretty okay uh
except that we have to write four which
is kind of
for futures it's not so natural but it's
you know it's pretty well the only the
only
minor annoyance is that we have to
introduce this intermediate results
uh doi response for example right this
in this other one
and uh you know introducing temporaries
is not such a big deal
although it does have a noticeable
impact on your
maintainability of the code right if
you're
interested in this i encourage you to
look at
martin scala days keynote where is was
all about style and that essentially
temporaries are tricky because if you
introduce them you should
provide a good name for them if the name
is bad
it just confuses the reader right and we
write code
so that it can be read well so it
confuses the reader if the name is bad
so you better spend some effort on this
but then
you ideally have a choice whether you
want to introduce a temporary or not so
that you can make an informed decision
of whether
having this intermediate result would
help the or the reader in this case
we're forced to introduce intermediate
results
so there's no choice really and
of course the names also are very
boilerplatey right
but it's not so bad so let's have a look
at another example
this one's more interesting basically we
do similar things right we have methods
that return futures
here we have a regular expressions that
regular expression
if you're new to scala or you haven't
used rank x before
you should have you should definitely
have a look i think it's a really cool
cool scala library um we can use
verbatim strings here
so you don't have to escape all the
backslashes that escape other
backslashes and so forth
so that's pretty cool and you can
pattern match
on these things very nicely so what we
do maybe i can just
explain that first so we have this
directx here and
we can actually match on a string and
then we can match against this date
pattern
and these month and day they will be
bound to the two the contents of the two
capture groups in the regex
right so you can directly extract what
the capture groups contain
it's a pretty natural way to do this so
but again the logic is pretty simple all
we do is we wait for this future
and then the body is a string that we
match against the date
and uh you know then we have the res
then we only have to
call this name of month method and
wait for its result and that's what we
put into the string
right um otherwise we say not found
you know so it's actually pretty simple
from the logic and it's
you can clearly understand this however
if you
try to do this using four comprehensions
then it looks like this right we're
basically
again we need these generators to look
at the uh
futures and sort of once that completes
we get a response
and so forth we do it for the second one
too
and the result here we have to match
against that
same way with the regex but now the the
trouble is
once the regex has matched we need to
have the result of a second future
okay but the only thing to get at the
result of the second future is using
another four comprehension
okay so we need to create a nested four
comprehension just to be able to look at
the result of this guy
right the result of name of month and
then
we yield the response now the problem is
the four yield
returns a future because our generator
reads from our future
okay but that means in the other case we
also have to provide a future
and of course that's going to be a
future that's already completed
because we know the result already and
you know so this introduces all kinds of
uh complexities
right so we have basically a whole list
of annoyances right we have to
name into temporary results we
absolutely are forced to do this
um then we have to use these nested for
comprehensions which not everyone is
familiar
is so comfortable with right and then we
have to realize oh this guy actually
returns a future
uh does that even work you know i mean
like this code is
is like it took jason and me like 15
minutes to come up with
the correct version of this and uh you
know whereas the
the code before you can you can write
down from beginning to end
like in 10 seconds right because you
just
directly express what you have to do
uh right whereas here
you you you gotta know you have to know
you know how four comprehensions
interact with um
with the like the future future api
map and flat mode and so forth okay
so i think that's a good example that
shows
that this can really help in practice
and
you know if you look at production
systems that
i've been doing a few times you have
you know people have like they use
futures and they chain them together in
like 15 to 20
steps right all using map and flatmap
and filter and so forth and you can
imagine like in this case we only have
essentially um you know
one flat map one map and another map
right but like imagine so these are only
three of those combinators imagine you
have 15 to 20 of those how this would
look like
right so uh yeah
um so this direct style basically so
this is what we call direct style
expressing things like this basically in
this sort of blocking style right
what what really what it provides you is
that you you don't have to
it doesn't force you to introduce uh
names for everything
right that's the first thing and it
really it does help
in practice i'm losing my mic
sorry about that
okay good
and the other thing is this direct style
really allows you to
express the control flow quite naturally
right
and the reason is that with a weight we
can essentially
suspend virtually
anywhere not really but virtually
anywhere in our scala
expression right within if else while
match try catch
you know just in between we just can
wait we can await the future whenever we
want to
whereas if we use four comprehensions or
something else we always have to like
somehow fit things into the into the the
this other style right so if you just
want to express a control flow
uh that makes things awkward right
to use for and also like map and flat
map it's really like map and flat map i
think are best
for uh if you transform data right or
streams if you want right for rx for
example makes a lot of sense
uh or um or collections right map and
flatmap but if you talk about futures
where it's really
mostly about control flow and like
suspension resumption and so forth
i think it's much less natural to use
these sorts of combinators
okay so now of course there are a couple
of things you have to keep in mind if
you use a weight
it has to occur within a directly
enclosing async
well if there's no async around it you
get a an error message which is pretty
readable in our case
that's good but you can't use a weight
within a closer right so if you have an
async block and
actually i'm going to show you an
example but if you haven't if if
there's an async block and between the
async and the await is a closure
uh that's that's not going to work
okay and that's similar similar for
local function classes objects within
async right in scala everything
can be nested right so you can have a
local locally defined
object or function right within an async
block no problem
but you can't use a weight within those
things i mean those are arguably not
that common
anyway so we don't think it's a big
restriction
also if you have an argument to by name
parameter you won't be able to
call a weight within that argument
because by name
actually you know translates to
generating a closure
so we end up with the first problem
but here's here's an example and it also
shows you how you can get around this
restriction
and here we can actually piggyback on
the work we did for futures
basically the idea is this right so
let's say we have an a-string block and
we we find ourselves in a situation
where
we do have a closure that we pass to map
in this case on a list
that's a well-behaved map you should do
that but right so you
you have a closure and within the
closure we just like to await
a future yeah and then of course
our macro is going to say well look you
can't do this
so what do we do well actually the
simplest thing to do
at least in this case in many cases is
to just wrap your expression that
contains the await in an async
right and now that of course going to
return a future
which means if you map a future
returning closure over this list well
then you get back
a list of futures which was not your
original
goal right the result of this list is
just a single
list map is just a single list that you
want to put into a future
but now we suddenly get back a list of
futures right
and but now to transform this list of
futures into a future of a list
we can just use this combinator
future.sequence
and this future companion object has a
bunch of those combinators to work with
collections of futures right and
so you know that's a pretty simple way
to to resolve this
issue right and so basically this
existing
uh you know fairly rich api for
programming with futures we can just
piggyback on that yeah and so the
you know these restrictions that we have
and like the usage of await
they don't feel that constraining in the
end
right
so now let's talk a little bit about
future things
and basically
there are a couple of interesting
developments um
one thing is sort of how do we debug
these things well
and um well one thing is that if
you have async and await a couple of
weight calls then your code is going to
be
chunked up essentially by the macro into
pieces of code that run
that run as tasks in a thread pool so of
course parts of the code
run on different threads essentially
right within your async block and so you
can't just like step
through it uh sequentially
but what we've been doing is basically
provide a
provide a mechanism that with a simple
import you can just
enable sequential debugging which means
async blocks are
executed sequentially on one thread
where basically all the awaits now
become blocking truly
blocking so the current thread will wait
until the future
that's the argument of await comes back
of course that you only want to use
while in debug mode when you want to
step through things
right but the the good thing is that the
stack of the
thread executing the async block remains
intact
throughout the whole async block right
so that's a pretty neat thing
the other thing i wanted to talk about
is has to do actually with uh with
reactive extensions and
donna and matt they already mentioned
that um
there's actually a lot of activity with
reactive extensions in the java
world with like netflix's effort and
and they're actually also working on
scala bindings and
you know there's lots of development
going on in in this space
and uh turns out that you can actually
connect async pretty nicely also to
to observable streams so uh for those of
you who haven't been at the
previous talk i just want to quickly
sort of
uh recap what uh
observables are which are basically at
the core of the reactive extensions
model
um basically we need two
traits in scala in java you would have
interfaces here
right so basically we need an observable
but that's sort of the main
trait right observable is something that
can
produce events and
you know what you can do is you can
essentially subscribe to that observable
if you want to observe it
right so you subscribe to it with an
observer
and the observer then you know consumes
all these events that come from the
observable
and what you get back as a result of
subscribing is a closable
or could be a subscription or something
like this that you can then
uh close if you're no longer interested
right so you can like do some cleanup
deregister the handler under the hood
the handlers under the hood and so forth
um and so the observer then is simply
a trait that it it needs at the least it
needs
three methods um essentially on next
which is a method that would be invoked
when an observed observable
produces the next regular event of type
t
yeah the other method you need is you
need to be able to respond to
failures i mean you don't have to but
you that's one
possible event that the observable can
emit essentially failure
with some throwable and the third event
is done which is emitted when the
observable
is done emitting events yeah so some
streams
are infinite they never emit on done
but in general they can they can also
terminate or stop producing new events
okay what i added here is some other
things that are
not so essential but we can extend
function
in scala write a function from try to
unit try is a very neat
container for sort of heap-based
exception handling as opposed to
stack based like try catch-based
exception handling
so if you haven't seen that have a look
it's used also in futures
but basically you can just use it to
essentially
make it more convenient to implement
observer observers right we just have to
implement
apply and undone in this case but it's
not so essential
right so with these two interfaces
you can do a lot of things right you can
build all kinds of
combinators that can you know create
observers observables and so forth
but with with async the the cool thing
is
we can with a small extension
that right now is experimental right so
we we can actually consume those
observables in a very convenient
way so basically what we can do is
instead of writing async here
we write r async okay so
reactive async and the idea is that this
thing
returns an observable instead of our
future yeah
so instead of just having something like
a future that has a single result
we can have it produce or create an
observable that can emit
many events and then the next thing we
introduce
is this await next or done where
basically
you pass in an observable and uh
you have this non-blocking way of you
know waiting for
the next event if there is one or
done if the stream has emits done
if there's no if there are no more
events right and then basically you can
get back
an option which in scala you have two
possibilities right none
and some some of some value or none
if the option is empty so none would
mean the stream
has emitted done right or it doesn't
publish any more events
but it's a very similar to a weight
except that you you sort of you wait you
await the next
event and then you can
so that's how you can consume streams
and of course you can consume as many
observables within your our async as you
want
but then you can also yield events so
this we can do with yield next where
basically
you know you just yield the next event
of the current observable
so the current observable is the one
that you're constructing
with this r async block right
so this rsync so you can essentially
produce
many events and they're basically uh
you know they're produced asynchronously
and
[Music]
you know there can be arbitrary many
observers
subscribe to this forwarder and and so
forth right
but this basically gives you a way to to
you know
create and consume observables in a very
natural style right where you don't have
to use
uh combinators that
you know that you're maybe not so
familiar with like here you can really
write
write straight line code to do this
this is also called ray just because of
the
the the constructs
rsync await yield and so forth but this
is again this is just an experimental
thing
i've written we've written a paper about
this
so if you google or i'm sure you can
find it somehow
but again like what i also want to point
out is that this is possible because
async is a macro so we can pretty easily
play with it and like come up with
variations and things like this right
and uh again like if you want to play
with this you're very welcome it's all
in github and
it's open source so you know it's a
really nice thing to
to play with
okay so let's uh conclude here um so the
async macro again i think
it it really does a lot of hard work for
you
and it's exactly the kind of work that
in my opinion other frameworks don't
really do
right they promise you oh your life will
be so much easier with
this awesome futures library or that
awesome actors library or
some other i mean there are of course um
you know
very deep uh deep um
facilities that some of these families
provide like akka for example or
or other frameworks like this right that
you wouldn't get
uh in any other way
um but sort of async does sort of this
this other aspect which is sort of
complementary which says well
sort of how can we do this basic
mechanism of like suspending and
resuming
right um and uh how to do this in a
non-blocking way
right so the generated code is is really
efficient so you sort of
you don't have to worry at all about
what comes out
when you can and it's actually it's
quite cool because the generated code
is pretty easy to understand because
what it spits out is a very simple
state machine of course the code is
going to be much longer than the
original code that you've written
but it's actually pretty easy to
understand what comes out
it just generates one class for your
async block which is a state machine
where that you can resume or suspend and
resume and so forth right you can like
say okay start from state
four right and the current values of the
results
are stored in the fields of the state
machine and so forth
it's rather simple what comes out and we
can make it efficient too so for example
boxing of intermediate results
we we can avoid pretty easily
and if you would like do this while
creating continuation closures then that
would for example be harder to do
so now what is this useful for there's
lots of places of course we can use it
out of the box for example play right
play uses futures a lot
the z14
and you know async is a you can it's
perfect fit for this
all you need to do is add the async jar
to your class path and you can
use it right and uh similar for akka
right aka
integrates actors and futures pretty
nicely and there again
if you want to wait for your futures you
can use async await um
and what would be really cool is if one
of the
high performance io libraries for scala
would make use of that still waiting for
this to happen
this would be i think a pretty good
pretty good fit as well
uh some uses of delimited continuations
can actually be
done with async await um
and uh yeah and it's it's totally
possible also to connect
it to other asynchronous apis doesn't
have to be futures
i've shown you rx um but you can do
other things as well
we have a an x we have a few extension
points in there
um that you can use
so the takeaway again like these two
method signatures
pretty easy uh async
create a future a way to wait for a
future and
looks looks like it's blocking but it
can
promise you it's not and uh
yeah so what what do you have right now
is potentially we have a
pretty stable implementation for both
scala 210 and scalar 11 to 11. so that
means actually you can
try it today right there's nothing that
prevents you from using it
and it's on github and you know
same as same license as scala which is
nowadays
bsd so and we've also written a
scala improvement proposal so that
because we sort of
or would like to have is to have this as
a new module of the scala distribution
yeah and uh
so here's a here's a plug before i end
there's a new mooc
which stands for massive massive uh open
online course
on uh reactive programming featuring
martin odersky who's gonna give a
keynote tomorrow uh eric meyer
of uh reactive extensions fame
and others um donna's former boss
as far as i know and and also roland
kuhn who is
akka tech lead at typesafe and
so these people are going to talk about
essentially reactive programming
abstractions like um
you know futures um uh actors
um reactive extensions uh observable
streams and so forth and also like how
to program with state and monads and so
forth and actually eric meyer really
wants to use async as well
so that's really exciting because we can
sort of
simplify a lot of people's lives and
make their make it easier to complete
their homeworks
so that's pretty cool and
the course in general i think it's
highly recommended
and you can even get tutoring personal
tutoring from typesafe as well
yeah so q a i don't know if you have
still time
a couple minutes so if there's questions
please feel free
are you referring to performance or yeah
so
performance evaluations compared to
other techniques or other approaches
our libraries we haven't really done
that
yet as we only
can say sort of like the closest
comparison that we have right now is
using the the
continuation passing style plugin from
scala right
and there we should run some experiments
to see how it
fares but the only thing that we can say
for sure
is that in scala async we don't create
as many closures
whereas with cps at each suspension
point you create a new closure
which is which has some impact
i mentioned the boxing which could be uh
different
um but yeah we haven't really done a lot
of
performance benchmarking but we
definitely want to do that should do
that
and uh because i'm actually quite
confident that
this is going to be faster than many
other things
any other yeah
are you do you think this is properly
stays a macro
or would this be better as a language
feature
okay so the question is uh is in this
scala improvement proposal
uh do we intend this to stay a macro or
would this be better
built into the language right and
i think the answer is
it should stay a macro if at all
possible because
it's uh um you know it it's
has a lot of benefits in terms of
packaging you you can decouple
you can decouple uh development and
maintenance from the from the mainline
uh this compiler right so it has all
these sort of
advantages and building it into the
language as a separate face in the
compiler
it wouldn't actually help that much
we think right um so
yeah we haven't seen it
we yeah we haven't seen anything that
would help us
if we would integrate it so
okay thanks